Christina has done over 5,000 dives with her sharks...
...and that's the key to getting close.
It's all about experience and understanding,...
...but her relationship is unique.
She is so close to her sharks, it's almost maternal.
I get emotionally attached to them...
...because sometimes, I look down on them like they are big kids:...
...just like all going for the same thing.
They change their behavior according to how I behave.
So if I relax, they tend to relax.
If I get really nervous and edgy, they get as well.
If I really would have to summarize what I feel when I finally have the sharks sleeping on my lap,...
...I would say, it's peace, peaceful.
But why on earth does she like to kiss them?
I kiss a shark because to me, it's the final act of gentleness.
And actually to tell you the truth, it was the only way,...